This episode is sponsored by Wren, a website
where you calculate your carbon emissions.
You can also sign up to make a monthly
contribution to offset your emissions
or support rainforest protection projects
by clicking our link in the description.
Somewhere around 470 million years ago,
something happened that shouldn’t have
been particularly striking. An
algae found its way onto land.
On its own, that’s not an unusual event. Over
billions of years, many different types of algae
have been able to find their way from
their freshwater or marine homes,
and carve out new lives in
niches they found on land.
But something was different about this algae,
something special. It would take
the algae on an evolutionary journey
through millions and millions of years,
changing our whole world in the process.
This algae turned the lands of this earth green,
altered the chemistry of our atmosphere,
and created homes for future life.
This algae would give rise to all
of the land plants we know of today.
Land plants are incredibly diverse. They’ve
had all those hundreds of millions of years
to get that way. Some have trunks, some
have flowers, some are low to the ground.
Even in a small patch of forest,
the variations can seem endless.
But all of those plants belong to a
single clade called the Embryophyta.
They’re divided into two broad
categories. There are the bryophytes,
which lack the vasculature to grow tall.
These include mosses and liverworts.
And then there are the tracheophytes, which
do have vascular tissues that carry water
and support their growth. These are,
well, just about everything else.
Trees, flowers, the plant climbing
up the corner of your room.
All land plants are descended
from an ancient member of a group
that’s still around called the Streptophyte
algae. But what was so special about this algae?
What enabled it to cultivate lands and take them
over to an extent that no other algae could?
We don’t know. It’s a fundamental mystery
of plants, because their existence
is just that remarkable.
Land is a stressful place to settle down on,
especially for an algae that is making its way
out of water. It would have had to contend with
so much more sun than before, unfiltered and
unrefracted by water. And that would put the
algae at risk for damage to its cell and its DNA.
On top of that, land is dry. It’s
easy to take water for granted when
you live in a pond or an ocean. But land makes
you even more dependent on the weather to provide
moisture, and on the morsels of water
you can gather from your environment.
So whatever algae made its way onto land, it
had to have contained incredible potential,
an enormous capacity to contend with the stresses
of an environment that was fundamentally
different from the home it was leaving.
While we don’t know exactly what that potential
looked like, scientists do have some theories.
One idea is that this mysterious ancestral
algae may have been able to cheat a little…
thatit was somewhat predisposed to life on land
because maybe it originally lived in freshwater,
where conditions are a little closer
to land compared to marine habitats.
It could also be that the streptophyte algae just
got here first. That maybe it beat other algae to
the punch, and that because it was first, it
had very little competition as it adapted to
the new challenges it was facing. It could thrive
without having to struggle for space or resources,
taking over the land and developing new structures
that would give it an advantage over any other
algae that tried to come onto land later.
Those are a few general theories about what
might have enabled the streptophyte algae to
adapt readily to land. But scientists also wonder
about the specifics—the details of the algae’s
appearance that would have morphed into the
traits that allowed embryophytes to dominate land.
And with the genetic tools available today,
scientists have made progress on understanding
more of this mysterious past. They’ve identified
the closest living relatives to land plants,
a group of streptophyte algae called
Zygnematales that includes this spirogyra. And
scientists have used this relationship to form
new hypotheses around ancient family traits.
Plus, there are many, many, many plants
in the world whose present-day forms
reveal the messy web that evolution has spun.
Take, for example, the stomata. You can see them
here, the microscopic openings that help the plant
take in carbon dioxide and release water.
The stomata is the kind of adaptation
that is key to plant survival on land, creating
many tiny valves that tune the plant’s interior
to best match whatever the changing world
around it demands. Scientists have even
found stomata-like openings on plant fossils
dating back more than 400 million years ago.
Not all modern day plants have stomata though,
including some bryophytes like liverworts.
So scientists had to dive into the phylogenetic
history woven into plant DNA to figure out that
the first land plants likely did have stomata,
and that bryophytes may have reduced their stomata
over time to the point that some
even lost their stomata entirely.
It’s all a bit like looking at your family members
today to try and figure out whether an ancestor
millions of years ago had dimples. The results
are a clue into one small feature of an ancient
algae that made its way onto land, a sign that it
may have had its own ancestral form of a stomata.
And if that’s the case, then perhaps an
ancient bryophyte inherited that stomata
only to eventually lose it through many cycles of
change and selection. It would hardly be the first
plant to take its inheritance from that remarkable
algae and then decide to do away with it.
These cells belong to Egeria densa. You
may have seen it before. It’s a plant
commonly found in aquariums. And yet this is
an embryophyte, a member of the land plants.
It just happened to have found
its way back into the water,
leaving behind the land that its
unknown ancestor once conquered.
It can be difficult to piece
together why anything in evolution
happens the way it happens. It’s easy, with
hundreds of millions of years of hindsight,
to describe these events with
some sort of inevitability.
After all, we live in a world covered in plants.
We live because of a world covered in plants.
To conceive of our world without plants would be
to conceive of a world without us as we are today.
But maybe the point of all this is that hindsight
is a convenient story we tell ourselves,
and that none of this was inevitable.
An algae came onto land, and it changed the
world. The rest, as they say, is history.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thank you again to Wren for sponsoring
this episode of Journey to the Microcosmos.
Wren is a website where you can
calculate your carbon emissions,
then offset it by funding projects like providing
clean burning fuel and cookstoves to refugees
in Uganda or a project that uses satellite
monitoring and drones to detect deforestation
in the Amazon Rainforest. We’ll need a lot of
different approaches to stop the climate crisis,
and this is one way that you can learn more about
your carbon contribution and take some action.
You’ll answer a few questions about your lifestyle
and they’ll also show you ways you can start
reducing your carbon emissions. No one can
reduce their footprint to zero, but using
Wren, you can help offset what you have left.
Once you sign up, you’ll receive
updates from the tree planting,
rainforest protection, and
other projects you support.
And we’ve partnered with Wren
to plant 10 additional trees
for the first 100 people who sign up
using our link in the description!
Before we go, we’d also like to say thank
you to each and every one of our Patrons.
Some of their names are on the screen right now,
and these are the people that make this channel,
and videos like this possible and we are so
grateful. If you’d like to become one of them,
you can go to patreon.com/journeytomicro.
If you’d like to see more from our
Master of Microscopes, James Weiss,
you can check out Jam & Germs on Instagram,
and if you’d like to see more from us, there’s
probably a subscribe button somewhere nearby.